he is none other than Reginald Martinez
Jackson here on the Rich Eisen show how
are you Reggie hey rich how you know
better for talking to you sir
what do you what do you think of Aaron
judge Reggie he's he's uh how's Suzy and
the kids they're all wow she is doing
great he's a matter of fact when I told
her today when I left she's like who's
on the show today said Reggie she says
say hi to Reggie so well I say hi to her
and you can't do nice I will do that
oh when I play what do you think of our
a judge Reggie what do you think you
have to take the same thing everybody
else thinks you know I've just seen him
says he was 20s 20 21 22 23 24 I've seen
him for six years so he's not a not a
surprise for me I didn't expect him to
hit 30 home runs in the first half dried
in 66 in first half and hit 320 the
first half but certainly the character
the makeup the way carries himself his
leadership skill set you know it's bad I
know its background I know where he's
from I know his parents and so I've been
around him for you know five years and
more and so you know his makeup is what
you really spot right away and then the
skill set and the strength and size is
is you know the presence is just there
and he's uh he's a gentleman a leader
lots of content and really smart person
you know people have I guess you'd
compare him to Jeter with character
we've had a few players that have come
through there that have been like that
since I've been there for xxx in their
30 years and so you think about guy like
Mariano and player like O'Neal and Tino
and those guys with such big makeup
Posada Pettit Yi and so the comparison
for him as a person you know are in that
realm and because I've seen him for a
long time
seen him develop and grow and mature as
a player in this person so the fact that
I know he's special is you know it's not
just the what I saw in the all-star game
that you know or what's happening this
year this year I certainly did not
expect this kind of year out of them but
I did expect success at the big league
level and and you know the ability to
hit 25 to 30 own runs because you know
we're weak we have a small ballpark now
and he hits a flyball that comes he hits
a flyball for him a routine fly ball and
there are a few guys I played with there
were like that
strawberry did it luzinski did it
McCovey did it start jewel did it dick
Allen did it Harper does it Trout does
it they hit fly balls for them that come
down on the other side of the fence
balls that aren't hit good according to
them ballparks are too small for some of
those guys Cabrera that kid up in
Detroit they hit a fly ball that it's
when it settles and it's missed it comes
down on the other side of the fence and
those guys hit 15 of those and then if
they hit 15 balls good they hit 30
it's unbelievable Reggie and in this day
and age though I've had a conversation
with fellow hall-of-famer John Smoltz
couple weeks ago Reggie that that that
kids don't mind of striking out as much
these days did you have did you have an
all-or-nothing mentality obviously
you're we all know how many strikeouts
you had in your career but did that
matter at all to you because there's a
lot of hand-wringing over today these
days
well I think I struck out too much and I
averaged somewhere 2500 in 21 years is
125 a year so but that's too many
and I think for 162 games if I would
have played them I to add 140 so hmm
that's too many strikeouts you can get
by with it this is Wow hold on let me
take this call from house I'm gonna call
my back okay you go I'll call you right
back addressed okay thank you
reg I mean seriously you could take that
I mean you could put me on hold for the
boss that's okay III wouldn't want that
can't have you hear what I'm saying now
hold on a second Reggie okay
now hold on real quick though I would
not be doing my job if I didn't ask this
question if that was George back in the
day would you been able to tell him no
no what you just told his son no not
hung up on you I might not even tell you
I acted like I was I just acted like a 1
on the phone oh man if that was Hank
oh I'd have probably got off the phone
because it could heat add some choice
words for me do okay well maybe house
listened to what you had to say about
Aaron judgment sure is all positive but
you were saying about strikeouts Reggie
I struck out too much now if you take
judge for the first 285 times he went to
the clave is 283 to be exact and he had
93 hits
hmm he had 93 hits
yes he had about 24 or 20 26 homers in
the 93 it's that's one in three so we
had a hundred strikeouts right you had
93 hits in a hundred and eighty three
trips to the plate that's crazy talk it
really is um I had 2500 strikeouts 25 97
20 what's use 2500 sure will round down
I had 90 590 680 at-bats but like that
and 26
[Music]
take the 2500 strikeouts and the 9600
at-bats goes down to 70 100 with 2,600
hits that's like three 60 or 70 when you
put the ball in blanks right so for guys
with that kind of power and the
statistical guys have told me this at
one of the highest averages or homers
per hit more than one in five like one
in four at 563 in 2600 hits is more than
four and a half so you got to put the
ball in play you got to put the ball in
play and so it's very important for that
the 200 strikeouts is too many hmm
if you hit 30 home runs I'll give you a
pass that you can strike out a hundred
and fifty but it's not laughable I don't
think I think it's something to concern
about there's significant value for the
team the player the run scored etc the
victories if we put the ball in play and
I'll throw myself we in there there you
go and I was I was pretty good when it
counted so I want to see the players and
our players focus on knocking those down
I'm comfortable
I think Erin I'd like to see him strike
out 125 130 that's enough because if he
puts the ball in play buddy you know
it's good for everybody
oh yeah with a Yankees this sure us and
in mr. October Reggie Jackson a couple
more minutes left with him I know you
were Steeler fan what do you think about
what the Steelers are doing with levy on
bail not giving them a long-term deal
Reggie I know you're out there watching
game day morning on NFL Network a lot so
what does that mean I am I am I'm
concerned about that situation I want
the relationship to be good because I
want everybody to be settled on the
field he's got some injury issues and
you've got some issues off the field
that you need to be concerned about so
you know I get I'm a huge fan of him and
Mike and
the Rooneys and all of that and so I
trust what they're doing all of it
they're about the team of franchise in
about the city and the brand they're not
about themselves I don't think anybody
is there and I think many of the players
fall into that it's the the room that
the students are that way that certainly
you can see what goes on with the
Patriots you start singing a whole
different tune when you play for some of
the teams in the NFL same way with the
Yankees the people from Frasier comes up
to us from Chicago he talks about the
franchise and so those are the things
that are very important so I think it'll
work out with Lady on he's an extremely
important piece and we don't know how
good we are because we didn't play in
New England last year with him and we
didn't play Denver with him near for hmm
couple more minutes left with you Reggie
do you have any two cents on Colin
Kaepernick on what's going on with him
in the NFL and Michael Vick I don't know
if you heard him say that he thinks that
it would be helpful if he cut his hair
what do you think well I don't know
about that I don't think your hair has
much to do with what you're doing on the
football field but I'm a very close
friend with in the tremendous respect
for Joe Montana and Joe seemed to think
it had to do with skill set and I tend
to lean toward that I do think he hurt
himself when he made the stand last year
because he I didn't agree with what he
did was the wrong situation in the wrong
venue you can't do that there's to my
got people that are my family has been
in the service and been injured in the
war and and there's so many people that
look at the flag as a as something for
freedom and something to stand for
democracy and way way more than what was
going on you know with the police force
etcetera so you can't use the flag in
the venue that's not yours with the
uniform that's not yours you got to do
that on your own in your press
conferences etc and be sensitive to the
venue you're in again when I'm in Yankee
Stadium
can't say what I feel like saying if I
had problems with what's going on in
baseball with the amount of minorities
that are there which I do I don't use
the Yankee platform for that I use my
own Reggie I appreciate the time please
come in studio I know you're in Southern
California as well my house is your's
please Romani think I'm going to do what
do you think I won't do soon as I hang
up call how Steinbrenner tell me I'm on
the phone now buddy okay take care of
register that's at mr. October on
Twitter so Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country
and audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me you'll enjoy